Nous venons de lire l'un des passages les plus beaux de toutes les Écritures et qui présente Christ avec beaucoup de superlatifs,
des déclarations très explicites à propos de sa gloire et c'est l'un des points que nous allons mentionner aujourd'hui,
ces déclarations capitales. On est encore en train de conclure cette introduction générale à la Christologie, à l'étude sur Christ lui-même.
Et si nous lisons les premiers paragraphes du chapitre 8 sur Christ les médiateurs dans nos confessions des fois,
nous allons retrouver ces paragraphes-ci, juste pour que vous ayez aussi un aperçu que même la manière de suturer l'introduction de ces chapitres,
elle est aussi basée dans cette introduction confessionnelle, les paragraphes 1 et 10, au chapitre 8 de la confession de foi,
« Il a plu à Dieu dans son descent éternel de choisir et d'ordonner le Seigneur Jésus, son fils unique,
selon l'alliance passée entre deux, père et fils, pour être le médiateur entre Dieu et l'homme. »
Donc c'est les chapitres sur les Christ, les médiateurs, et Christ est donc introduit dans l'ordre de notre étude sur les doctrines,
il est introduit dans les cadres du thème de la médiation, dans les cadres du thème de la rédemption.
Donc je ne vais pas faire tous les rappels à nouveau, mais quand on a vu l'ordre, on a vu qu'on a respecté deux principes principaux.
Le premier principe, c'est de toujours venir du haut vers les bas,
de considérer déjà les grandes doctrines par la perspective des dieux pour après considérer qui nous sommes.
Et nous avons aussi considéré que toutes les révélations bibliques,
elles sont progressives envers les Christ,
et plus tard, elles restent centrées sur les Christ pour enrichir notre compréhension du Christ.
Et donc, quand on étudie, par exemple, l'autorité des Écritures,
c'est pour qu'on soit sûr que nous pouvons aller à une source fiable qui puisse nous enseigner à propos des dieux.
Mais notre intérêt, il est très pratique, car à partir du moment où on contemple Dieu tel qu'est révélé dans la Bible,
nous les désirons, mais nous voyons immédiatement combien indignes
et combien impossible c'est de nous approcher des dieux.
Et donc, on a besoin des Écritures pour nous enseigner non seulement qui Dieu est avec précision,
mais comment nous réconcilier avec Dieu.
Et donc, c'est comme si Dieu était en train d'établir des catégories
pour que nous puissions traverser une espèce d'école élémentaire
et apprendre les besoins de faire confiance aux Écritures
pour être sûrs que nous serons devant un Dieu qui n'est pas le fruit de notre imagination,
mais d'un Dieu véritablement Dieu et glorieux.
Et en même temps, c'est Dieu véritablement Dieu et glorieux.
À cause de notre condition actuelle, il devient désirable, mais inaccessible.
Et ensuite, on commence à créer des catégories pour comprendre pourquoi on est dans cette condition.
Donc, on a considéré cet ordre, Écriture, Dieu, homme créé à l'image de Dieu ou les œuvres de Dieu,
chute et ensuite, on a contemplé la doctrine de la rédemption ou la doctrine de l'Alliance.
Et l'une des leçons principales, c'est que toute cette didactique d'Alliance dans la Bible nous a enseigné
que nous avons besoin d'un médiateur parfait entre Dieu et les hommes.
Et ces médiateurs parfaits, pour plus qu'ils soient typifiés par plusieurs médiateurs
dans l'histoire de l'Ancien Testament,
il n'est jamais trouvé dans sa perfection jusqu'à ce que Christ arrive.
Et donc, on a fait la distinction entre
la connaissance qu'on a eue jusqu'ici
du Fils des dieux,
c'est-à-dire la deuxième personne,
la deuxième personne de la Trinité,
quand on a étudié les chapitres sur Dieu
et sur la Sainte Trinité.
Donc, la personne
du Fils des dieux,
c'est la personne qu'on a étudiée.
Maintenant, quand on évoque Christ,
et ça, c'est une distinction pas facile
pour les enfants de rétenir, quand on fait les travails
sur les catéchismes avec mes enfants,
c'est car ils font
trop la confusion
entre Dieu et Jésus.
OK ?
Donc, qui nous a créés ?
Ils répondent vite, parfois, Jésus.
Et c'est vrai dans un sens,
car Dieu nous a créés à travers sa parole.
Mais c'est important d'être précis dans ces distinctions.
Quand on considère Dieu dans sa position en tant que créateur,
on veut garder quelque part
cette notion de Dieu
propriétaire, juge, ultime,
qui doit garder cette position
pour juger aussi la rédemption
et les fils qu'il doit encarner.
Et à plusieurs reprises,
ils vont dire correctement,
si on dit qui est Jésus,
c'est Dieu.
Dans un certain sens,
c'est correct,
car Jésus est le Fils des dieux
et donc,
il est une des personnes
dont la Trinité subsiste.
Donc, il est véritablement Dieu.
mais si par Dieu,
dans notre compréhension,
on est en train de penser
à l'ensemble du Dieu unique,
là, on peut avoir aussi des imprécisions à cet égard.
Et donc, des fois,
c'est un peu compliqué
pour nos enfants de saisir,
mais c'est très important pour nous
d'avoir la précision des compréhensions
du pourquoi la Bible nous révèle
ces distinctions
dans l'être des dieux
ou dans la Sainte Trinité.
D'accord ?
Et donc, ici,
on est en train de considérer Christ
et Christ,
il doit être pensé
dans les cœurs de chrétiens
dans son ensemble.
Christ est cet être humain
qui est venu pour être les Messies
qui avaient une double nature,
la nature divine
et la nature humaine.
Donc, c'est les fils des dieux
incarnés
et quand on parle des Christ,
on n'est pas en train de penser
tout simplement
au fils des dieux
dans sa participation
intratérinitaire,
dans sa préexistence éternelle
avant qu'il rentre dans les mondes.
Quand on pense à Christ,
on doit penser déjà
au fils des dieux
dans son œuvre messianique,
incarné.
Vous comprenez ?
Si je suis en train de dire ?
Ok.
Et donc, là,
on a considéré,
on commence à considérer
cette Christologie,
les fils des dieux incarnés,
dans sa fonction
rédemptrice,
donc en tant que médiateur
entre Dieu et homme.
Donc, on verra
toute la richesse
que cela concerne,
mais on a considéré
d'abord,
dans notre introduction,
des raisons
pour étudier
à propos du Christ.
Et donc, ici,
on est en train
de considérer,
en lisant
les premiers paragraphes,
la pertinence
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Il a plu à Dieu
dans son dessein éternel
de choisir
et d'ordonner
le Seigneur Jésus,
son fils unique,
selon l'alliance passée
entre deux
pour être les médiateurs
entre Dieu et l'homme.
Donc, cette déclaration,
elle est une déclaration
qui est déjà
très puissante
dans les éléments
qui sont désignés
envers les Christ,
médiateurs
entre Dieu et l'homme.
car même si nous allons
nous approfondir
dans la compréhension
biblique de ces vérités,
nous savons
que l'intervention
des dieux
dans l'histoire
en Jésus-Christ,
c'est une intervention
qui a marqué l'histoire
et qui traitait
les enjeux
les plus importants
de toute l'humanité.
Et donc,
c'est une question
d'intégrité intellectuelle,
tout simplement,
pour nous
qui sommes une race
qui est très intéressée
à l'histoire
et qui étudiant
plusieurs personnes
importantes dans l'histoire.
Ça devrait être
une obligation
pour toutes les personnes
de toutes les religions
car tous les peuples
ont au moins
une idée,
une notion
de cette personnalité
qui a divisé l'histoire.
Parce que toutes
les principales religions
globales
ont un avis
envers les Christ,
une idée
à propos du Christ
et surtout nous
qui habitons
dans l'Occident,
nous avons
notre histoire
reconnue
comme divisé
entre avant Christ
et après Christ.
Donc là,
il y a déjà
une pertinence générale,
une pertinence globale,
mais particulièrement
pour les christianismes.
OK ?
Car il n'y a
aucune religion
dont la personnalité
principale
soit si capitale
pour la religion.
Les religions
peuvent exister
rien que par leur
système de religion,
par leurs enseignements.
Leurs livres
sacrés
ne dépendent pas
pour que la religion
continue d'exister
de leur personnalité
principale.
Dans notre cas,
ce n'est pas
la même chose
car
les christianismes
ne peuvent pas
exister sans Christ.
Et
il ne suffit pas
d'avoir
une idée
qui est
la moindre déviation
de la compréhension
de ce qui est
ou qui est
le Seigneur Jésus
et son œuvre.
Donc voilà pourquoi
on a beaucoup parlé
sur ça.
Le Nouveau Testament,
il est préoccupé
principalement
avec la précision
sur la bonne interprétation
de qui était Jésus
et quelle est son œuvre.
Et la moindre déviation
à cet égard
peut nous envoyer
à l'enfer.
Donc une personne
qui croit en Christ
qui n'est pas
les Christ bibliques
n'est pas sauvée,
ne sera pas sauvée.
Il ne suffit pas
tout simplement
de répéter
les noms de Jésus
dans une prière.
Il faut
savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on croit
à propos du Christ
et voilà pourquoi
la préoccupation
du Nouveau Testament
c'était de nous décrire
de manière très claire
comment Christ
accomplit
toutes les promesses
de l'Ancien Testament.
On n'arrive même pas
à comprendre
l'Ancien Testament
sans Jésus Christ
de notre côté.
On n'arrive qu'à
comprendre
de manière
correcte
et précise
l'Ancien Testament
avec Jésus
déjà pleinement révélé.
Et donc
quand on considère
cet aspect
c'est important
pour nous
d'être très précis
dans notre étude.
La semaine dernière
on a passé
considérer
non seulement
les raisons générales
qui devraient marcher
pour tous les êtres humains
mais les raisons
que la Bible
elle-même
nous donne
à propos du Christ.
Et là
on a un peu médité
sur cette question
des prophéties.
Et là
on revient à nouveau
juste pour vous reconnecter
avec les paragraphes
de la confession
qui commence
en nous disant
il a plus à Dieu
dans son
descent
éternel
de choisir
et ordonner
le Seigneur Jésus
son fils unique
selon l'alliance
passée entre deux
dans l'éternité passée
pour être
les médiateurs
entre Dieu et l'homme
les prophètes
les sacrificateurs
etc.
Donc qu'est-ce que je veux
appeler attention
c'est que nous avons
bien sûr
une source fiable
et infiniment fiable
qui est
le Nouveau Testament
et le Nouveau Testament
il est fiable
car c'est un travail
qu'on va dire
sous inspiration divine
ok
l'enregistrement
historique
de la part des personnes
qui ont pu vivre
avec Christ
ou des personnes
qui étaient sous la supervision
de ceux qui ont vécu
avec Christ
le Nouveau Testament
a été écrit
sous
la supervision
apostolique
et la plupart
des textes
du Nouveau Testament
ont été écrits
soit par des apôtres
soit par
les frères
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
soit par
des disciples
directs
des apôtres
et l'un des arguments
principaux
pour la fiabilité
du Nouveau Testament
c'est que ces hommes
eux-mêmes
réclamaient
avoir vécu avec Christ
être témoinculaires
etc
donc on a
cet enregistrement
historique
qui est
le plus fiable
de toute l'histoire
par rapport
à n'importe quelle personnalité
on ne va jamais trouver
des ressources
qui soient si fiables
et qui respectent
les critères
les plus exigeants
de l'historicité
de la science historique
si vous voulez
ok
et nous savons
davantage
qu'il y a
cette supervision
du Saint-Esprit
qui a inspiré
l'enregistrement
du Nouveau Testament
mais là
on est en train
de faire recours
au Nouveau Testament
qui est en train
de faire un travail
sur quelque chose
qui s'est déjà passé
sur des faits
qui ont été observés
et je vous ai présenté
les prophéties
comme en étant
non seulement
la capacité des dieux
de prévoir les choses
par anticipation
ou de manière passive
mais les prophéties
comme un argument
que Dieu lui-même
utilise
dans l'Ancien Testament
pour se présenter
comme seul vrai Dieu
comparativement
à d'autres
clairement comparativement
à n'importe quel être
ou non
on ne sait même pas
ce qui va se passer
avec nous
jusqu'à la fin
de cette journée
on n'a pas la capacité
de prédire
pour plus d'argent
qu'on ait dans un compte
bancaire
et que nos billets
soient achetés
pour aller quelque part
on ne sait pas dire
qu'on sera là demain
vous comprenez
mais les faux dieux
et les vidants
c'est comme ça
vous dites voyants
les voyants
réclamaient avoir
la capacité
de voir le futur
et Dieu
il défiait
notamment ces choses
car c'est les seuls
capables
de changer les plans
d'un moment à l'autre
car Dieu
il n'est pas en train
de fonder
sa prévoyance
ou ses prédictions
ou ses prophéties
sur la base
de sa prévoyance
il est capable
de prévoir
les choses
car il a tout
planifié
il a tout décrété
et il conduit
et gouverne
toutes choses
voilà pourquoi
ces paragraphes
commencent
il n'a plus Dieu
dans son dessein
éternel
de choisir
et d'ordonner
et plus tard
il dit
dans ces mêmes
paragraphes
pour être
en temps voulu
racheter
appeler
justifier
sanctifier
etc
c'est à dire
Dieu a un temps voulu
pour que Christ arrive
c'est dans la plénitude
d'être
etc
et donc
c'est pour
qu'on ait
une notion
des prophéties bibliques
qui soit
véritablement
suffisamment élevée
à l'autorité
qu'elle est présentée
telle qu'est Dieu
car si nous avons
un enregistrement
fiable
de l'histoire du Christ
en regardant
vers l'arrière
ce qui est encore
plus extraordinaire
mais également fiable
c'était la manière
dont Dieu
a préparé
la venue du Christ
par anticipation
la précision
avec laquelle
Dieu avait
donné des prophéties
et des promesses
liées à Christ
c'est les temps
qu'on a pris
la semaine dernière
c'était de voir
les principales prophéties
qui touchaient
les Christ
et qui ont été
données par anticipation
il y a des
rechercheurs
qui ont fait
des études
des prophéties croisées
qui remarquent
presque 4000
prophéties
qui s'accomplissent
le long de toute la Bible
et au niveau
des précisions
extraordinaires
plus de 300
prophéties
qui vont être
liées
spécifiquement
à des accomplissements
extraordinaires
du Christ
on a parlé par exemple
des membres percés
on a parlé
des déclarations
qu'il a fait à la croix
on a parlé par exemple
qu'il est pour sa venue
les Christ
devaient venir
des trois lieux
géographiques
différents
et on voit
de manière très claire
comment il accomplit ça
avec l'Egypte
avec Bethlehem
et avec
Nazareth
et donc nous voyons
de manière extraordinaire
tous ces accomplissements
et donc
les prophéties
elles sont
selon Dieu lui-même
voilà
une motivation
suprême
pour considérer
les Christ
il est au centre
du livre
le plus respecté
de toute l'histoire
le plus extraordinaire
le plus apprécié
les livres sacrés
qui est
le seul vrai
livre sacré
et qui a
pour centre
les seigneurs Jésus
ok
et donc
les seigneurs Jésus
étant les centres
des prophéties
c'est
comme si
Dieu était en train
de nous présenter
lui-même
l'une des motivations
principales
pour étudier
à propos du Christ
donc étudions
ensemble Christ
car il est au centre
de la révélation
biblique
il est au centre
des prophéties
et aujourd'hui
nous allons considérer
!
les déclarations
capitales des écritures
donc on a considéré
les prophéties
la semaine dernière
et une autre
motivation biblique
on a présenté
on est en train
de présenter
ces deux principales
motivations bibliques
pour étudier
à propos du Christ
et c'est notamment
ces déclarations
glorieuses
que la parole
fait du Seigneur Jésus
de manière explicite
est-ce que vous êtes
en train de suivre
ces fils conducteurs
pour nous convaincre
et nous motiver
même si on pense
et on sait
qu'on n'a pas besoin
mais c'est pas au hasard
que Dieu lui-même
essaye de nous motiver
dans sa parole
à étudier les Christ
et donc ce sont
des déclarations
qui vont faire
la distinction
entre les christianismes
et n'importe quelle autre religion
les déclarations
qui sont faites
à propos du Christ
vont faire que
quand on pense
aux religions
on s'évole
plus au moins
dans cette situation
où Christ pose
la question
à ses disciples
qui le peuple
dit que je suis
et ce sont
des très belles opinions
que ce soit
l'un des prophètes
Élie
Jérémie
etc
mais
qui vous dites
qui je suis
et ce sont
ces déclarations
superlatifs
tu es les Christ
les fils
de Dieu vivant
qui déterminent
qui est
le vrai Christ
et donc
une vision
plus faible
ou moins élevée
que celle-là
n'est pas suffisante
pour sauver personne
voilà pourquoi
les musulmans
vont être d'accord
que Christ
était un grand prophète
et que
pour certaines religions
plus polythéistes
ésotériques
il était
l'ange des lumières
ou la lumière
la plus développée
et presque
toutes les religions
vont vouloir
savoir apprécier
le Christ
mais pas
à point de reconnaître
qu'il est
le fils des dieux
lui-même
par contre
les déclarations
bibliques
elles sont
tout simplement
extraordinaires
donc
les
les paragraphes
de la confession
qu'on vient de lire
nous présentent
des déclarations
superlatives
qui sont aussi
trouvées dans l'écriture
mais
je vais les lire
à nouveau
quelques portions
de paragraphe 1
qui nous disent
par exemple
Seigneur Jésus
son fils unique
seul ou le médiateur
sangulier
entre Dieu
et l'homme
prophète
sacrificateur
tout dans les sanguliers
car il est
par excellence
roi
chef tête
et sauveur
de son église
héritier
de toutes les choses
juge du monde
et qui
de toute éternité
elle est propriétaire
du peuple
pour être
sa postérité
et donc ici
nous voyons déjà
des déclarations
très explicites
donc si jamais
il y a eu un être
humain qui reçoit
une telle description
ça serait de la folie
de ne pas considérer
qui est cette personne
les paragraphes 2
aussi de la confession
des fois
à plan des déclarations
très merveilleuses
à propos du Christ
donc les fils des dieux
la seconde personne
de la trinité
est un vrai
et éternel dieu
égal
et même
sous-sistance
avec les pères
donc
c'est lui
qui a pris sur lui
la nature humaine
donc aucune religion
ne va jamais
oser faire
une telle déclaration
que Dieu
ait pris sur lui
la nature humaine
que les dieux
éternels
inaccessibles
sans
viennent se mêler
avec la nature humaine
et donc là
on voit aussi
donc des déclarations
très puissantes
à propos du Christ
et donc
pour être plus biblique
dans nos déclarations
je vous propose
selon la proposition
de Lloyd-Jones
d'identifier
au montoir
d'entre elles
et donc
la Bible
elle nous présente
Christ
ok
comme les seigneurs
souverrants
et suprêmes
et donc
à nouveau
nous savons
qu'il y a
Dieu
et notamment
Dieu les fils
en participant
à la sainte trinité
il est
aussi créateur
aussi
les souverains
mais ici
nous sommes en train
de dire
qu'il y a
Christ
le Seigneur Jésus
ok
la personne
la plus importante
de notre foi
il est
véritablement
les créateurs
les dieux
les fils
incarnés
et il est
même
après avoir
pris sur lui
ou pour lui
la nature humaine
il a accompli
son oeuvre
il est mort
il est ressuscité
il n'a pas délaissé
la nature humaine
il continue
d'exercer
ses fonctions
de garder
ses titres
qu'il avait
avant même
l'incarnation
aujourd'hui
avec un corps
en tant que médiateur
parfait
entre Dieu
et les hommes
en nous faisant
co-participants
de la nature divine
car il a gardé
les corps
avec lesquels
il a incarné
les corps
qui a été
glorifié
après sa résurrection
et donc les seigneurs
il est souverain
suprême
c'est lui
qui possède
et qui soutient
toutes les choses
donc on vient de lire
Colossians chapitre 1
verset 12 avant
il a l'image
du Dieu invisible
verset 15
les premiers-nés
de toute la création
car en lui
donc là les premiers-nés
ça donnait aussi
la possibilité
pour des mauvaises
interprétations
pour l'hérésie
la grande crise
entre Arius
et Athanase
car pour Arius
l'emphase
des premiers-nés
voulait dire
que quelque part
il a pu être créé
à un moment donné
les premiers-nés
dans la conception biblique
c'est pour donner
plus d'importance
à la notion
d'héritage
c'est un langage
qui a été développé
avec les êtres humains
pour illustrer
quelque chose
qui se passe
dans cette prérogative divine
qu'il est éternellement
généré du Père
mais en étant
les seuls fils
uniques des dieux
des dieux véritables
qu'il est les premiers-nés
dans ce sens
où il a les droits
d'héritage
pour toujours
ok
car en lui
ont été créées
toutes choses
donc voilà
ça serait une contradiction
dans les mêmes passages
de considérer
les premiers-nés
comme quelqu'un
qui a pu être créé
comme les autres choses
si lui-même
est celui
par qui
toutes les choses
ont été créées
vous comprenez
donc il est
en lui
ont été créées
toutes les choses
c'est-à-dire
il a les droits
d'héritage
à toutes les choses
car toutes les choses
ont été créées
en lui
qui sont dans les cieux
et sur la terre
il est avant
toutes choses
et toutes choses
subsistent en lui
il est la tête
du corps
de l'église
il est
les commencements
les premiers-nés
d'entre les morts
afin d'être
en tous les premiers
car Dieu a voulu
que toute la plénitude
habita en lui
et il a voulu
par lui
réconcilier
tout avec lui-même
dans ce qu'il y a
sur la terre
et ce qu'il y a
dans les cieux
en faisant la paix
par lui
par les saints
de sa croix
remarquez bien
il y a plein de choses
ici
qui nous savons
qui ont eu lieu
lorsqu'il n'était pas
encore incarné
mais il y a plein de choses
ici qui sont
tellement liées
à Christ
qui a déjà
incarné
car c'est une référence
à celui
qui a fait la réconciliation
par les saints
de sa croix
donc c'est pour affirmer
que c'est la même
personne qui a existé
depuis toute l'éternité
qui a pris ses corps
qui a gardé ses corps
c'est Jésus même
qui est celui
qui a créé toutes les choses
et qui soutient
toutes les choses
par sa parole
puissante
donc est-ce qu'il sait
quelqu'un
digne d'être étudié
c'est celui
dont ma respiration
et les battements
de mon coeur
dépendent
pour que je sois
soutenu en vie
tout simplement
et toutes les personnes
devraient étudier
à propos du Christ
car c'est cette personne là
qui soutient toutes les choses
donc on peut penser
à Matthieu 28
tout pouvoir
m'a été donné
dans les scelles
sur la terre
Ephésiens 1
et 23
il a tout
mis sous ses pieds
et il a donné
pour chef suprême
à l'église
qui est son corps
la plénitude
et celui
qui remplit
tout en tout
1 Corinthiens 15
car il faut qu'il règne
jusqu'à c'est
qu'il ait mis
tous les ennemis
sous ses pieds
et Daniel 7
et 14
qui nous disait déjà
j'ai regardé pendant
mes visions nocturnes
et voici
sur les noées
des cieux
arriva quelqu'un
semblable
à un fils de l'homme
on lui donna
la domination
la gloire
et les règnes
et tous les peuples
les nations
et les hommes
de toutes les langues
les servirent
si nous croisons la Bible
et que nous lisons
ce type de passage
ça devrait être
un signe très effrayant
que dans nos dévotions
très faibles
et charnelles
on soit encore
plus intéressés
à ce que la Bible
peut parler à propos
de nous
qu'à propos du Christ
nous allons vers la Bible
pour trouver Christ
pour contempler la gloire
de la révélation
du fils des dieux
c'est pour ça
que nous lisons
les écoutures
les juges suprêmes
de l'humanité
donc non seulement
il est celui
par qui
toutes les choses
ont été créées
et donc tout ce que
vous pouvez voir
des beaux
des puissants
d'intelligence
dans la création
sont trouvés
infiniment
plus glorieux
en Jésus Christ
la source
de toutes ces choses
il est le propriétaire
par contre
il a été aussi
désigné par Dieu
comme celui
qui va juger
toutes les personnes
les vivants
et les morts
j'ai eu
les privilèges
dans un déplacement
récent
là
Béat est allé
à Nantes
jouer au volet
et je suis allé
voir
pendant une journée
et les conducteurs
d'un Uber
qu'on a pris
étaient
mouzoumans
marocans
et j'ai eu
la possibilité
de partager
l'évangile
avec lui
et c'était
une conversation
importante
car on était
d'accord
sur certains points
la sainteté
des dieux
bien sûr
la justice
des dieux
bien sûr
mais un intérêt
assez incohérent
de sa part
à la possibilité
que Dieu
étant miséricordieux
puisse
voilà
permettre
qu'on arrive
au ciel
ou au paradis
rien
qui est par
sa miséricorde
ou sa grâce
et quand même
il a dit
que ça dépend
de notre
procédure
de nos bonnes oeuvres
de notre comportement
donc bien sûr
je l'ai dit
bon
ça pourrait dépendre
de nos bonnes oeuvres
mais
si nous avons
une idée des dieux
qui soit suffisamment
correct
ces dieux
doivent être
100%
purs
et si Dieu
est 100%
sûr
pur
pardon
et juste
il y a
une manière
de voir les péchés
qui ne pourrait
voilà
qui personne ne pourrait
être épargné
car si je compare
ma vie
avec Hitler
je peux sentir
que je peux aller
au paradis
mais si je compare
ma vie
avec les critères
des sainteté
de Dieu
personne ne peut
aller au paradis
et bien sûr
que j'ai donné
cet exemple
qui
bon clairement
je pense que
dans les sens
comment on voit
dans cette semaine
aussi
avec les nouvelles
d'actualité
très peu de choses
peuvent être considérées
comme plus abominables
qu'est la pédophilie
qu'il est mal fait
contre
les personnes
les plus vulnérables
qui sont les enfants
et donc
quand on considère
dans ces cadres là
et surtout
dans les particularités
de la personne
principale
de cette religion
dans nos conversations
qui étaient très délicates
j'ai pointé
ces péchés
comme exemple
pour dire
comment pourrions-nous
imaginer
que Dieu
aurait pu épargner
cet île des péchés
le problème
c'est que
Dieu
il est infiniment
sans
et entre nous
comparer
Hitler
ou la pédophilie
peut nous faire
sentir à l'aise
mais quand
nous cherchons
à nous comparer
à la sainteté
absolue
des dieux
nous sommes tous
condamnés
et la grande question
passe à être
si Dieu est Dieu
il est 100% juste
et si Dieu est 100% juste
c'est impossible
que personne
soit sauvé
sur la base
de sa propre performance
et là
j'ai par la grâce
de Dieu
eu l'occasion
de présenter
comment pour moi
le christianisme
est la seule religion
qui peut véritablement
satisfaire
ces puzzles
car Dieu est 100%
ça devrait dépendre
de nos performances
mais personne
ne peut performer
et donc on a besoin
d'un médiateur
pour qu'il soit
en même temps
juste
juge
et c'est lui
qui justifie
les pécheurs
en souffrant
lui-même
la punition
et donc la Bible
elle nous dit clairement
et il lui a donné
les pouvoirs
des jugés
parce qu'il est
les fils de l'homme
Jean 157
acte 17 31
parce qu'il a fixé
un jour
où il jugera
les mondes
selon la justice
par l'homme
qu'il a désigné
c'est dont il a
donné
à tous
une preuve certaine
en les ressuscitant
des morts
et ça c'est intéressant
Christ a été
évidemment
pointé
comme
les seuls
capables
de juger
l'humanité
attention à ça
en ayant
vaincu
la mort
c'est à dire
si la mort
elle est véridique
des condamnations
sur une race
pécheresse
et nous tous
allons traverser
la mort
et aucun
d'entre nous
ni d'aucune religion
n'est jamais
revenu de la mort
qui serait
le seul homme
capable
de juger
les autres hommes
nous nous jugeons
entre nous
sachant que nous sommes
tous corrompus
et celui
qui sera
le seul
d'entre les hommes
qui sera
le juge
de tous les hommes
c'est celui
qui a vaincu
la mort
car il a été
trouvé par Dieu
comme quelqu'un
qui a été
mis à mort
mais pas par ses fautes
il a souffert
la punition
la condamnation
de ceux
qu'il représentait
mais il ne pouvait
pas être
rétenu à la mort
pas tout simplement
à cause
de sa nature divine
mais car il était
innocent
et un innocent
ne peut pas être
gardé dans la mort
et donc
il a été
désigné par Dieu
par la résurrection
comme les seuls
juges
de tous les êtres
humains
en étant un juge
capable
humain
donc si vous voulez
comparer vos vies
rappelez-vous
que vous devez
comparer vos vies
à l'homme
Jésus Christ
et c'est selon
ces critères-là
que nous serons
jugés
en tant qu'être humain
personne
ne sera
épargné
sauf ceux
qui ont été
punis
en Christ
à notre place
donc le roman
nous dit
que c'est
ce qui paraîtra
au jour
où
selon mon évangile
dit l'apôtre Paul
je jugera
par Jésus Christ
les actions
sécrètes
des hommes
dans cette conversation
c'était sûr
qu'il pourrait
s'éventer
de ce qu'il a pu
manifester
publiquement
mais personne
ne peut s'éventer
des pensées
c'est comme
disait Schaeffer
dans les jours
de jugement
c'est comme si
dans tout
ce qu'on pense
tous les mots
qu'on a dit
et qu'on n'a pas dit
mais qu'on a pensé
et qu'il n'a pas
écouté
c'est comme si
on vivait
avec un enregistreur
autour du cou
et que toutes les choses
qu'on est en train
de faire
parler
et penser
seraient enregistrées
et dans les jours
de jugement
il suffit
de taper
play devant Dieu
car nous
pouvons faire semblant
entre nous
et même
penser qu'on peut
faire semblant
devant Dieu
mais quand on arrivera
à ces jours-là
et qu'on met
play devant
la claire
justice des dieux
Schaeffer propose
que nous-mêmes
nous dirigerons
tête baissée
vers l'enfer
car selon les critères
de nos propres jugements
on n'arrive jamais
à être à la hauteur
des jugements
qu'on utilise
pour juger les autres
combien plus
de jugements des dieux
voilà pourquoi
Paul dit à Timothée
j'étais conjure
devant Dieu
et devant Jésus Christ
qui doit juger
les vivants
et les morts
et au nom
de son apparition
et de son royaume
donc imaginez-vous
que vous êtes présentés
à la réalité
du fait
que
nous serons tous
jugés par Christ
donc est-ce qu'on est
ou on n'est pas
intéressés
aux juges
c'est l'intérêt
de tous les êtres humains
quand on
quand on va
quand on fait
en bêtise
et qu'on doit
se présenter
devant les juges
c'est comme on rêve
si jamais
on a la moindre amitié
avec les juges
ou qu'on sache
au moins en fait
quelle est la manière
de procéder
de ces juges
quelles sont
les demandes
de sa justice
quelles sont
ses exigences
est-ce qu'il y a
la moindre possibilité
de régler mes comptes
avec ces juges
et donc voilà pourquoi
nous devrions étudier
Christ
nous trouverons
un juge
qui ne va
jamais
laisser passer
aucun péché
mais qui va
trouver aussi
une manière
de faire retomber
sur lui
les jugements
qui devraient retomber
sur nous
et donc il faut
étudier
à propos de ces juges
voilà pourquoi
dans les prédications
!
d'évangélisation
de l'apôtre Paul
souvent il va
conclure avec
cette déclaration
Dieu
vous êtes là
en train de tâtonner
pour chercher Dieu
mais Dieu
a déjà fixé
un homme
qui va juger
les morts
et les vivants
donc la position
des juges
justice
du juge
doit être rappelée
donc nous
devrions étudier
à propos du Christ
car il est
les juges
il est aussi
présenté clairement
comme les seuls
médiateurs
entre Dieu
et l'homme
il est les seuls
par lesquels
nous pouvons
être réconciliés
avec Dieu
et connaître Dieu
Christ
est l'unique
médiateur
il n'existe
aucun autre
schéma
vers Dieu
aucun autre
fondement
du salut
et Christ
lui-même
l'est dit
donc d'autres
passages
du Nouveau Testament
les déclarent
clairement
Jésus
qui est
Hébreu 12
Jésus
qui est
les médiateurs
de la Nouvelle Alliance
et du sang
de l'aspersion
qui parle mieux
que celui d'Abel
acte 4
il n'y a
des saluts
en aucun autre
car il n'y a
sous les ciels
aucun autre nom
qui a été donné
parmi les hommes
par lesquels
nous devions
être chover
1 Timothée
2 5
car
il y a
un seul Dieu
et aussi
un seul médiateur
entre Dieu
et les hommes
Jésus Christ
hommes
Luc 24
et 47
Jésus
lui-même
il leur dit
ainsi
il est écrit
que les cris
souffriraient
et qu'ils
ressusciteraient
des morts
les troisième
jour
et que la répentance
et les pardons
des péchés
seraient prêchés
en son nom
à toutes les nations
à commencer
par Jérusalem
donc le Messie
est celui
et le seul
qui est le médiateur
entre Dieu
et les hommes
il n'y a aucun autre nom
et aucune religion
n'arrive à faire
un tel type de déclaration
n'ose faire
ce type de déclaration
et tous veulent
que nous soyons
pluralistes
le problème
c'est que
la personne
la plus importante
qu'elle a jamais vécu
dans l'histoire
les créateurs
les juges
les seigneurs
Jésus Christ
lui-même
fait ses déclarations
c'est comme
à présenter
ses trilèmes
c'est à Silius
car à partir du moment
où Jésus dit
je suis les chemins
la vérité
et la vie
nul ne vient
au Père
qui est par moi
il dit
soit
on n'a pas l'option
de traiter Jésus
tout simplement
comme un bon maître moral
comme quelqu'un
qu'on puisse
s'emprunter
pour notre religion
faire des éloges
pour éviter
les disputes
Jésus ne peut pas
être qu'un bon maître moral
ou un bon exemple
ou un bon leader
car soit
il était
complètement fou
car aucun être humain
qui est
qui est un être moral
avec un bon fonctionnement
de la raison
ne va réclamer
divinité
exclusivité
comme schéma
envers la vérité
ou envers
Dieu
donc soit
il était
fou
soit il était
un menteur
soit
il était Dieu
Christ
était
Dieu
soit
il était
un menteur
soit
il était
un fou
on n'a pas
d'autres options
et donc
quand on est
en train
d'échanger
avec les autres
personnes
plus tôt
on doit
les présenter
ces trilèmes
car avec
nos amis
musulmans
il ne peut pas
être qu'un prophète
il réclame
être les seuls
chez moi
il réclame
être Dieu
il faut venir
à terme
avec ces déclarations
si on fait
les moindres
droits
envers Christ
il faut aller
jusqu'au bout
et donc
si il dit
être
les seuls
chez moi
la seule vérité
la seule
médiation
envers Dieu
on ne devrait
avoir
aucun
autre intérêt
donc
il est souverain
les battements
de mon coeur
dépend
de sa bonne
volonté
il est
les juges
il est en train
de me permettre
de vivre encore
mais plus tard
c'est lui-même
qui va me juger
donc je fasse
un bon usage
du temps
qu'il me donne
de la vie
qu'il permet
que je vis
afin
de régler
mes comptes
avec lui
donc je devrais
étudier
avec la crainte
d'étudier
mon juge
et à la lumière
de lui
qui a la toute puissance
et qui a
la justice
dans ses mains
heureusement
en étudiant
je trouve
qu'il est
le médiateur
et toutes ces choses
devraient nous pousser
à étudier
la glorieuse doctrine
du Christ
en tant que médiateur
et les seuls médiateurs
entre Dieu
et les hommes
et donc
nous devons nous approcher
du thème
en reconnaissant
avant tout
toutes les limitations
c'est Dieu
Dieu lui-même
Dieu les fils
qui va
incarner
qui va prendre
un corps
véritable
littéral
pour soi
et qui pour
qu'il arrive ici
en tant qu'un vrai
autrement
un miracle
extraordinaire
doit avoir lieu
et traiter
par la Bible
comme les plus grands
de tous les miracles
de tous les mystères
donc on sait
qu'il y a
des bénéfices
énormes
en termes
d'adoration
et des saluts
mais les mystères
préservent encore
beaucoup des limites
pour notre raison
et donc c'est
tout simplement
une doctrine
qu'on n'a pas
le choix
de ne pas étudier
à cause
de ses difficultés
mais qui doit
être étudiée
avec un sens
des craintes
des révérences
des privilèges
et d'adoration
et donc
c'est même Christ
qui avant
son incarnation
s'est manifesté
à Moïse
dans les buissons ardents
par cette apparence
des feux
c'est le Christ
qui est venu
habiter
dans ce tabernacle
humain
et donc
on a les miracles
de l'immanence
des dieux
Dieu Emmanuel
du Dieu transcendant
et inaccessible
on a
les miracles
d'un Dieu
qui s'est fait
susceptible
au temps
étant lui-même
éternel
je suis
on a
ces mystères
entre la relation
entre la nature
divine
et humaine
du Seigneur Jésus
et on a
ces mystères
aussi incroyables
qui est
la naissance
ou la conception
virginale
comment prendre
la nature humaine
sans être contaminée
par les péchés
originels
et nous allons
nous plonger
dans ces mystères
avec l'aide
des dieux
à tous ces égards
pour commencer
à passer
à la considération
de la doctrine
les premiers
aspects
de la doctrine
sur les Christ
les médiateurs
et notamment
la doctrine
de l'incarnation
donc on est en train
pensée
au médiateur
parfait
entre Dieu
et les êtres
humains
et Christ
comme médiateur
parfait
il viendra
comme les dieux
la deuxième
personne
de la trinité
qui fait
habitation
entre nous
qui devient
chair
et donc
les deux
premiers
paragraphes
de la confession
vont traiter
surtout
cette question
de l'incarnation
ok
et donc
c'est les plus
grands mystères
révélés par Dieu
la parole a été
faite chair
elle est habitée
parmi nous
et l'apôtre Paul
dit à Timothée
dans la première lettre
au chapitre 3
verset 16
sans contredit
les mystères
de la pièce
étaient grands
Dieu a été
manifesté
en chair
ok
les sens
de l'incarnation
c'est la chose
la plus importante
pour nous
de retenir
aujourd'hui
et nous devons
être très précis
dans nos déclarations
et dans notre
compréhension
à cet égard
car la moindre
déviation
dans la compréhension
de la doctrine
de l'incarnation
représente
des hérésies
très graves
qui finissent
toujours
par détruire
les salules
humaines
dans la conception
biblique
et donc
quel est l'essence
de l'incarnation
c'est que
les fils éternels
des dieux
appris
une véritable
nature humaine
la naissance
de Jésus
n'est pas
les commencements
d'une personne
nouvelle
celui
qui est né
à Bethléren
elle est même
fils éternel
des dieux
ok
donc il faut
que nous déclarions
les choses
avec beaucoup
de précision
les fils éternels
est rentré
dans les temps
et dans l'histoire
dans notre conception
de l'incarnation
c'est de nous rappeler
de la pré-existence
comme je nous présente
au commencement
il était
avec dieu
et la parole
était dieu
c'est le commencement
pour nous
c'est pas le commencement
pour lui
ok
donc c'est les fils
éternels des dieux
qui a pris
une véritable
nature humaine
c'est la seconde
personne de la trinité
qui a assumé
l'humanité
sans cesser
d'être dieu
donc dieu
a envoyé
son fils
dans une chair
semblable
à celle de péché
roman 8
et donc
à bête
nous trouvons
l'entrée
dans l'histoire
du fils
éternel
et non
les commencements
de son existence
c'est clair pour vous
vous remarquez bien
les déclarations
et voilà pourquoi
les deuxièmes paragraphes
de la confession
le premier
nous dit clairement
il a choisi
désigné éternellement
les seigneurs
Jésus son fils unique
ok
comme celui qui viendrait
et le deuxième
paragraphe de la confession
nous dit le suivant
les fils des dieux
la seconde personne
de la trinité
est un vrai
et éternel dieu
égal
et de la même substance
qu'est les pères
ayant accompli
la plénitude des temps
a pris sur lui
la nature humaine
ok
donc là
l'une des choses
les plus importantes
d'être clair
dès le départ
c'est notamment
que la personne
qui est venue
et qui a pris pour lui
un corps humain
qui a pris pour lui
l'humanité
pas que les corps
mais l'humanité
c'est Dieu lui-même
c'est Dieu les fils
c'est la personne
de Jésus
donc l'incarnation
à nouveau
non seulement
Christ le médiateur
est au centre
des prophéties
des écritures
mais quelque part
l'incarnation
elle-même
non seulement
on a des prophéties
qui nous parlaient
de la venue
du Messie
ou du médiateur
mais on a des prophéties
qui nous parlaient
que la Vierge
allait concevoir
un enfant
et les noms
qu'ils recevraient
c'était des titres
éternels
on voit
comment
Malachie
va nous dire
de manière
très glorieuse
vous dites Malachie
ou Malachie
Malachie
4-2
qui le dit
mais pour vous
qui craignez
mon nom
s'élèvera
les soleils
de la justice
et la guérison
sera sous ses ailes
ou les saluent
donc là
il est en train
de décrire
la venue du Messie
comme un soleil
qui s'élèvera
entre nous
les soleils
notamment
de la justice
et Philippiens
qui confirme
ses prophéties
avec toute explicité
en disant
lesquels existant
en forme de Dieu
n'a point regardé
comme une proie
arrachée
d'être égal
avec Dieu
mais s'est déplié
lui-même
en prenant
une forme
de serviteur
en dévenant
semblables hommes
et ayant paru
comme un simple homme
il s'est humilié
lui-même
s'est rendu
enveillissant
jusqu'à la mort
et même la mort
de la croix
ok
et donc
tous
les développements
de la révélation
de la rédemption
elles passent
par cette préparation
de la venue
du Fils des dieux
incarné
en venant
habiter avec nous
et même bien sûr
les symboles
les tabernacles
les temples
toutes ces significations
d'un Dieu
qui habite entre nous
qui habite avec nous
et donc
la gloire
de l'incarnation
est la chose
la plus importante
pour nous
à considérer
quand on pense
à l'incarnation
donc pensons
par exemple
que personne
n'aurait la capacité
même d'envisager
cette possibilité
quelqu'un a déjà dit
que même si on avait
eu l'idée
personne n'oserait
suggérer à Dieu
donc rien
que d'avoir été créé
à partir de la poussière
et d'avoir reçu
de la part de Dieu
les privilèges
d'avoir été créés
à son image
ça nous met
dans une position
de privilèges
en finie
et personne
n'oserait
demander à Dieu
plus que ça
de dire
c'est merveilleux
mais c'est pas suffisant
pourquoi
au lieu de nous faire
tout simplement
à ton image
toi-même
ne deviens pas
un d'entre nous
pour qu'on soit
encore plus proche
de toi
vous voyez
l'incarnation
elle est tout simplement
glorieuse
car les dieux
qui s'est révélé
à nous
de manière glorieuse
directe
par la relation
par les propositions
par les déclarations
mais aussi
en nous faisant
son image
et en nous mettant
en relation
avec lui
il est allé
au-delà
de tout simplement
manifester sa gloire
dans les choses
qu'il a créées
en comprenant nous-mêmes
mais il a voulu
tellement
qu'on ait la capacité
de lui connaître
plus en profondeur
qu'il s'est fait
cher aussi
pour qu'en contemplant
les visages du fils
on voit les pères
et on connait
les pères
c'est lui
qui m'éconnait
connait mon père
qui m'a envoyé
c'est lui
qui m'évoit
voit mon père
donc dans
ces plans glorieux
qui a compris
notre rébellion
responsable
de laquelle
nous sommes coupables
n'a jamais pris
Dieu par surprise
tout faisait partie
déjà de son plan
sage et éternel
afin de nous révéler
sa gloire
d'une manière
qu'on ne pourrait pas
contempler
si ce n'était pas
à travers
l'incarnation
donc l'incarnation
elle est importante
car elle révèle
les plus grands
de tous les mystères
Dieu entre nous
Dieu avec nous
Dieu plus accessible
que jamais
pour adoration
et pour contemplation
mais aussi
la nécessité
de la doctrine
de l'incarnation
car elle est
nécessaire
pour
notre rédemption
pour qu'on ne va pas
à l'enfer
pour qu'on soit
réconcilié
avec Dieu
et donc
la diligence
de l'histoire
de l'église
pour protéger
avec les confessions
les déclarations
et du Nouveau Testament
lui-même
pour protéger
la précision
de notre compréhension
à propos
de la doctrine
de l'incarnation
elle passe
non seulement
par les privilèges
de pouvoir considérer
la gloire
des dieux
révélée dans l'incarnation
mais aussi
par la protection
du salut
lui-même
car la moindre
déviation
nous lance
à l'extérieur
du salut
lui-même
la rédemption
dépend
de l'incarnation
telle
qu'elle a dit
présente
voilà pourquoi
on ne peut pas
ouvrir beaucoup
d'espace
au scepticisme
il y a des personnes
qui disent
bon
il a de la difficulté
à croire
que Christ
est né
véritablement
d'une vierge
mais au moins
il a compris
l'évangile
là
on ne peut pas
être dans cette démarche
car si Christ
n'est pas né
d'une vierge
il n'y a pas
d'évangile
si Christ
n'est pas
vrai Dieu
il n'y a pas
d'évangile
si Christ
n'est pas
vrai homme
il n'y a pas
d'évangile
s'il n'est pas
100% Dieu
100% homme
s'il n'est pas
né d'une
conception
virginale
nous n'avons
pas quelqu'un
qui puisse
représenter
vraiment
l'être humain
mais qui ne soit
pas contaminé
par les péchés
on n'a pas
quelqu'un
qui soit
d'une valeur
telle
qu'il y ait
son œuvre
puisse représenter
un nombre
si grand
d'âmes
et donc
si on touche
à la moindre chose
dans ces déclarations
qui ont d'affaires
avec beaucoup
de précisions
et beaucoup de tact
ont fini
par supprimer
l'évangile
complètement
et donc
nous devons
savoir et connaître
que les premiers
intéressés
tels qu'est
Pierre lui-même
les présentes
à des
conceptions
un peu
flux
de l'incarnation
du Christ
ou de la double
nature du Christ
c'est Satan
lui-même
à qui
Jean
c'est Jean
ou Pierre
je pense que c'est
Pierre
vous allez m'aider
là
désolé
qui
c'est
lui
qui
nie
Christ
est
venu
en chair
Jean
première
vas-y
je te laisse
chercher
merci
sinon
c'est
Jean
je pense
c'est
1er
Jean
c'est
selon
mes notes
mais sinon
je te laisse
lire
pour nous
aussi
tout
esprit
qui
confesse
que
Jésus
est
venu
en chair
est
des
dieux
tu peux lire
la suite
et 3
je ne vais pas rentrer
dans les implications
apologétiques
mais c'est clair
pour vous
par cette
lecture
qui nous sommes
déjà dans la fin
des temps
j'espère
que ça soit
clair
pour vous
et donc
l'esprit
de l'antichrist
qui est déjà
dans les mondes
et bien sûr
c'est cet esprit
qui est animé
surtout par l'intérêt
et la puissance
de Satan
c'est l'esprit
satanique
derrière
et donc
depuis
les nouveaux
testaments
l'intérêt
de Satan
était
notamment
donc à chaque fois
que Satan
voit qu'il ne peut pas
empêcher
l'accomplissement réel
de l'œuvre du Christ
il essaye
de détourner
la compréhension
la foi
la joie
et plusieurs autres choses
donc il essaye
toujours de naviguer
avec les vents
et donc dans certains moments
on voulait tellement défendre
la vraie nature divine du Christ
qu'on a presque supprimé
la nature humaine
pour compenser
on est allé dans l'opposé
et on disait
non c'est vraiment un homme
qui a été expié
qui a se fermé
et Dieu l'a aidé
l'accompagné
mais ce n'était pas vraiment
Dieu
et donc on est dans
l'autre extrême
mais la seule conception
véritablement
qui sauve
c'est celle
qui affirme clairement
que Christ
que Dieu les fils
est venu en chair
et c'est lui
qui a fait l'expiration
qui a fait cette œuvre
et voilà pourquoi
dans l'histoire de l'Église
on voit
les efforts
du Nouveau Testament
et dans l'histoire
de l'Église
des premiers siècles
surtout
la précision confessionnelle
qui nous conduit
à cette considération
de la doctrine
donc
on a fait
aujourd'hui
quelques affirmations
déjà introductoires
par rapport
à cette conception
et l'importance
de la précision
de la doctrine
et
je pense que
ce que nous pouvons
retenir
pour que pour la suite
on soit encore plus précis
dans notre compréhension
c'est
que
la personne
qui
a
incarné
qui a pris
pour lui
encore
ce n'était pas
une personne
nouvelle
qui est apparue
ce n'était pas
une personne
humaine
sur laquelle
Dieu
a possédé
quelque part
où les fils
est venu
habiter ensemble
ou avec
une autre personne
mais c'est
la personne
elle-même
de la deuxième
personne
de la Trinité
donc Dieu
les fils
qui est venu
qui a pris
une chair
véritable
donc nous allons
rester aujourd'hui
avec la lecture
du paragraphe 2
nous allons arrêter
avec la lecture
du paragraphe 2
et la semaine prochaine
nous allons
nous plonger
plus dans la doctrine
de l'incarnation
pour considérer
quelques déclarations
des précisions sur elle
et notamment
plusieurs textes
publics
et ensuite
considérer
une autre sous-division
de la doctrine
du Christ
le médiateur
donc on commence
avec l'incarnation
et bien sûr
on passe tout de suite
à la considération
de la doctrine
de la naissance
virginale
ok
de la conception
virginale
du Christ
ok
et nous allons
comprendre
ces gens
donc lisons ensemble
les paragraphes
2 de la confession
qui nous aident
à conclure
mais aussi
à introduire
la prochaine étape
les fils des dieux
la seconde personne
de la trinité
étant vrai
et éternel dieu
égal
et des mêmes substances
que les pères
ayant accompli
la plénitude du temps
a pris sur lui
la nature humaine
avec toutes les propriétés
essentielles
et les infirmités
communes
de cette nature
mais sans péché
ayant été conçu
par la puissance
de son esprit
dans les sangs
de la Vierge Marie
dès la substance
de celle-ci
ainsi
de nature entière
parfaite
et distincte
la divinité
et l'humanité
furent
inséparablement
jouantes
et une seule personne
sans conversion
sans composition
ni confusion
cette personne
est vrai Dieu
est vrai homme
et cependant
un seul Christ
les seuls médiateurs
entre Dieu
et l'homme